in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Shan
and Rebecca are with us hey guys how are
you better than I deserve is it Shan the
dumb pronounce that wrong you did it
great job Dan good deal where you guys
from fine I'll be down there after the
first year I'm speaking at a Calvary Oh
first and first weekend of the year
looking forward to it they're launching
our Financial Peace University through
the whole church oh very cool stuff
we're excited about that well welcome to
Nashville you're here to do your
debt-free scream yes sir and at least it
wasn't bitter cold when you came north I
know got a night got a nice Tennessee
day today so uh what kind of debt did
you pay off how much about 90 K cool on
how long did that take well I want to
tell you the truth Dave it's about three
years and three months but the truth is
we took a year to think about it in in
that three that's right we do to think
about it the second year that we kind of
thought about a little bit more and we
actually really got gizelle intense the
last 12 months okay so the bulk of it
happened last 12 months like over half
of it well over half of em cut household
income during that time we started about
60 an hour above 100 way to go guys what
do you guys do for a living
we work in ID I'm a clinical software
trainer mm-hmm and I'm an information
technology manager perfect very cool all
right what kind of debt was the 90
thousand most of it was student loans
and a thousand was for credit cards or
$800 was for credit cards and some
medical bills okay so the last year
you've just been on you cash float a big
chunk of this Oh big chunk AC went out
we cash flowed that we had cars used we
cash flowed that as well had dental
issues you go from thinking about it for
two years to getting really crazy
serious gizelle intense what happened we
would start budgeting and then like we
would create the budget but then we
wouldn't stick to it and then we would
start over again and about two years
before we took the class we took the FPU
class in Plantation Florida mm-hmm we
were married two years when we took the
class
and so we had like accounts and a lot of
our finances were not together at that
time so it took some time for us to kind
of decide how we were gonna create our
financial plan to go there and when
actually when we first took the class
she we went on the trip to Jacksonville
I might might have been a trick on hers
but she trapped me in a condo for one
week to do our budget yeah we got it
yeah love it that's fabulous so what
happened a year ago what changed so
within those three years I was
contracting and she only had started
listening to the show and at that time I
didn't know about the show and so he'd
come home and tell you know stories of
and be really excited about different
things that he heard on the show and I
was contracting at the time and he said
I heard on the show that if you're not
like working full-time cuz we were I was
kind of deciding on if I was going to
start working full-time when I or just
think contracting to stop paying off the
debt and I was like you know I don't
care what but but so he was saving like
whenever whenever I would get paid with
my check he would start saving it so he
saved a lot of that and once I started
working full time we took a chunk of it
and put it towards the debt but what
made you change your intensity I'm glad
you asked that so we have a friend of
mine who's actually a real good part of
our support system he came in and he was
sort of a mediator at that point or one
of the mediators and between the two of
you yes and he said hey you guys have
this you know you have this amount why
don't you guys agree upon
you know amount that you could pay and
save and so he was the right person to
say that you know because if I said it
it wouldn't have gone well and he said
they probably wouldn't gone well so he
was sort of the catalyst at that moment
to help get us through but before that
as a child was started me personal on
his journey and she was also
undiscerning as a child as well with her
parents is that my father
in a country in Jamaica and he told me
the story where he would use about five
years old and he'd walk X amount of
miles a usual story walk ten 15 miles to
class but he said during he was so
poured that when they had recess or time
to go out and play he would take his
lunch break and he would drink water and
water fountain from the water fountain
and go back in class and that was his
lunch he had no food um and that sunk
that song came with me it stayed in for
the rest of my life and I said you know
I felt really bad for my father and I
was like you know I don't want that to
ever happen happen again never ever ever
any one of our family members so it was
this class that actually helped put us
on the same page
and just to add to that last year or
maybe two years ago you had a special
for financial coaching and so we called
rusty who's here in a lobby with oh yeah
and rusty helped us work that budget he
really simplified it for us we and there
was that about a year ago yes okay so
the mediator and rusty oh yeah gave you
a plan and that got you energized okay
that makes sense because I mean you kind
of went from sort of kind of screwing
around with it for two years I'm
thinking about it I mean you went to
game on I was trying to see what flipped
that switch and so a good coach helped
Oh both of those were good coaches it
sounds like a mediator and then rusty
one of our coaches yeah so very cool
well congratulations you guys so what is
the key to getting out of debt
great coaching great coaching very cool
and and the budget like we noticed that
when we didn't because we didn't stick
to it all the time and and we noticed it
big time you know we overspent when we
didn't use a budget or we forgot certain
things like going through your budget
plan helped us to remember things like
the license renewal or life insurance
that's the annual fee like annual fees
yeah so it helped out a lot with that
and we also it also helped us with
setting up like separate funds so like
when the AC broke down we had you know
funds to pay for that and things like
that so our emergency fund was still
intact so thank you so much also want to
add that throughout the process of three
half years we were going through some
marital problems and the process helped
us get through it and I was talking to
Rusty today and who's the great coach am
and I first started I was thinking yes
we'll pay off the debt everything will
be great
but I only thought about it from the
financial aspect I didn't think about
what would happen actually when we
finally finished the whole process of
what happens to you how you have to grow
the things you have to change about
yourself and how you have to just grow
exponentially to be able to tackle that
kind of thing you know Jim Rohn said if
you want to be a millionaire it's a
great friend for anybody to try and do
it because not the financial aspect but
for who you have to become so I want to
encourage any family that's out there
any couple that's out there hey if
you're not doing well you guys are not
getting along don't worry about just
keep going forward keep moving forward
you guys will get your act together and
it will work out because we could do it
anybody could do congratulations you two
very well done
all right Shannon Rebecca Fort
Lauderdale Florida $90,000 paid off in
three years and three months making
sixty up to $100,000 a year count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
well done you two well done and that's
killer that is how it's done you guys
would be so rich so fast and be able to
do so much not only for yourselves and
for your family but for others